there's no getting away from the 13%
committing 52% of the violent crimes in
this country 13% of the population and
it's largely black men by the way so
it's really about under 6% so why is
that why is that and
how are usually white men talking about
statistics 13% of the population 52% of
the crimes which doesn't help young
black boys it's you're not listening and
this is not a productive conversation
not to use my data for anything to use
your dat not we do not approve of being
on camera or doing anything party
consent State and you already did whole
demeanor and everything about you
shifted shifted with the idea of
microaggressions and white fragility
because that's racist go back through
this and Rewind it I've never once made
a generalization that because you are
black you can't X or Y you've both done
it at least eight times be sles if it
was for you baby your for white people
is white privileg must fragility means
when white people are afraid to confront
the fact that they might have racism or
might have racist thoughts